[Applause]
[Music]
happy Thursday everybody uh yeah well
except for those sad bastards at Disney
it's gotten so bad they're going to fire
7 000 people as part of a significant
transformation it's the biggest
transformation since kilmead's lunch
turned into a butterfly
ew yeah he eats caterpillars but you
didn't know that
the job cuts are part of a bigger
strategy to save five and a half billion
dollars which is more than enough to pay
for the sex change surgeries for the
Pirates of the Caribbean
foreign
do not dead name them
but this is what happens when you go
woke the saying is you go broke and you
can blame the Cowardly execs who let the
woke turn Disney into the joke it is now
I mean you want to talk about
transitioning forget Leah Thomas look at
the Disney product gone are the days
when their movies and cartoons actually
taught children life lessons I mean
remember that wooden Peg legged lion
little Pinocchio
[Music]
he taught children not to FIB or you'll
get eaten by a whale and die
to be honest I never understood what
whales have to do with lying until I saw
the view
I don't get it
and remember that Little Mermaid
Ariel
with clam shells for a bra and a mouthy
Little Crab
nobody told her drugstores have
medicines for those
but she taught a generation of young
women that you can overcome a disability
I mean she was a cartoon mermaid
that's a hard life if she can't stand up
how can she make me a sandwich oh sexist
would say
[Music]
and then uh
there's the 101 Dalmatians what lessons
did you learn from that well I learned
that there are better puppies for your
coats
I mean it's God they're kind of ugly
when you think about it Cinderella
taught us that love comes not from your
dress or your station in life but from
the shoes you're wearing
and Bambi Bambi taught us to always wear
orange in the forest
all right
and what about this beloved classic
come along now hey sit down
I'm just kidding hey you guys want to do
some coke I gotta think where we can
find some my dealer got shot last night
and I'm looking for a new supplier drugs
are terrible you shouldn't talk like
that oh don't be a women love to
complain about every little thing
that's it come here little fairy scale
guys snort this angel dust it'll get you
high oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna write a screenplay
that was pretty good that was the best
thing they've ever done
[Applause]
I actually forgot what my point was
well my point is Disney used to be about
universal life lessons now it's not
take the proud family on Disney plus a
cartoon designed to turn kids into
permanent victims with no agency of
Their Own by supplying them with only
the tools to Envy others it's hate
America 101 and they don't even hide it
Joy Reed should sue for copyright
infringement
roll it
this country was built on slavery which
means slaves built this country till
this land from sea to Sea to Sea first
there was rice tobacco sugarcane they
Whitney did his thing and Captain became
and we weren't soldiers four million
strong fighting for America's freedoms
even though we remained America slave
built this country this of slaves
continue to build this slaves built this
country you get that slaves built this
country
thank God for this song Because I had
never heard that before but a song about
slavery there's nothing controversial
there but like a Kennedy on a
Massachusetts Bridge
it takes a turn for the worse
thank you
roll some more money because it's true
and we the descendants of slaves in
America have earned reparations for
their suffering and continue to earn
reparations every moment we spend
submerged in the systemic Prejudice
racism and white supremacy that America
was founded with and still has not atone
form slaves built this country well
they're those words we've come to know
and love systemic Prejudice racism white
supremacy otherwise known as the
national anthem for Democrats
again this is for children but it's not
in a classroom it's kids entertainment
what's next snow white privilege and Her
Seven old entitled white men
but hey if you thought Lincoln freed the
slaves you'd be dead wrong
didn't they say it for you to sleep but
slaves were men
hey we can free ourselves emancipation
is not Freedom Jim Crow segregation
redlining Public Schools feeding private
prisons where we become slaves again as
we celebrate June 10th time our account
is still outstanding cause this country
was built on slavery with me slaves
built this country
so we say freedom isn't free they say
freedom isn't Freedom they just took a
dump on the graves of 365 000 Union
soldiers and Abe Lincoln so what's the
point of all that well it's about
retribution and not reconciliation it's
brainwashing as entertainment and while
some might call it a history lesson it's
a bitter filter that primes a child to
enter life with a deficit and that whole
is caused by hate I mean why cooperate
with others who are different from you
if they're related to someone centuries
ago who might own slaves or might not
own slaves that doesn't seem to matter
really I mean does anyone check your
family tree before they call you a
racist
but thank God we have Disney to cleave
children from each other when they
should be learning to play with each
other this isn't food for thought it's
fodder for re-segregationists
we need to be a part they think from
each other so if you want your kids to
start life pissed off with a chip on
their shoulders the size of a can of
Pringles have them watch that it's
called the proud family but with
messages like that there's nothing to be
proud of
[Applause]
let's welcome
tonight's guests
she's nursed more cocktails than kids
Fox News anchor Julie Bandera
he's funnier than Joe Biden trying to
put on a jacket comedian Jim Florentine
when life gives her lemons she rubs them
in my eyes Fox News contributor tattoo
and he's so tall he needs binoculars to
see his own feet my Master's sidekick in
the NWA World Heavyweight Champion
Islands
[Applause]
Julie we joke about you being a terrible
mother but it's funny because it's true
would you let your kids watch this hell
no no why not absolutely not first of
all you know South Park remember and and
Beavis and Butthead those to me were
controversial cartoons I watched them in
my 20s by the way that dates me but
nonetheless you know when they would
kill Kenny at the end of every South
Park I thought that was the worst of it
this is absolutely despicable and it
goes against that whole woke
anti-rheteric uh that they are pushing
the woke Theory
um and and critical race Theory down our
children's throats what's really
disturbing about this there's so many
levels is that they are actually
children in this and these are children
that are preaching the critical race
Theory where they're trying to erase
history they're trying to say that that
Lincoln is not responsible for
abolishing slavery and in fact we
emancipated ourselves let me tell you
about emancipation when I was 17 I was
so bad that my dad wanted me to be
emancipated on my 18th birthday so you
don't need to talk to me about
emancipation and emancipation is freedom
I'm just saying I can't wait to get out
to college that's an interesting
Harrison I happen to know a lot about
emancipation I sure do I was a crazy
partier throughout my parents crazy it
is forced into emancipation I was forced
into emancipation no but this is forcing
children to basically want to erase
history we are proud to be here where we
are today because of writing the wrongs
of history and slavery is a stain on
American history and it's something that
should be taught in order to teach
people the way to go forward not to go
backward and that's what they're trying
to do here to our kids yeah that's a
thing about this Tyrus is that it's like
everybody there's no one's arguing about
learning history but there's certain
things here that are that are being
replaced and that is like why isn't
dizzy Disney just trying to get kids to
enjoy life well because they're trying
to appease the mob yeah they're not
interested in kids this was about some
artistic person getting their poem out
uh I would one thousand percent watch
this with my kids for one other reason
they're gonna have a lot of questions
afterwards like how angry was the little
white girl who was saying that her own
people were white Supreme like that's
just craziness but
watch it I'm like uh now I will tell you
what history is right okay and and
reparations
here's the thing on reparations
when it came out it was never about
money it was about opportunity and what
was the thing during that time owning
land was your best opportunity to be
successful and leave something for your
children we no longer we've replaced
land with opportunity in this country we
all have that I'm sitting here because
of opportunity everyone in this chair
had an opportunity of some foreign
others you took advantage of you didn't
we all have different roads and bumps
but that's the difference what this
group does or this artist does is they
don't want opportunity
they want the finished product they want
to be given the rewards without the work
and this country is about work
regardless of what color you are
you missed the uh the good old days of
why is my shirt all screwed up that's
the important problem
do you miss the good old days of
Disneyland when it was you know just
like Snow White and some dwarves
I never liked Disney no no uh why not
it's it's for children and any adults
that go and by themselves without kids
yeah they got issues it's a it's a
rested development is what that is yeah
they should not they should message us
as a sex offender
by themselves so you shouldn't be around
kids like that it's creepy I don't know
what happened to your child but get over
it you're a grown man walking around
with Mickey ears on taking pictures next
to Mickey that's just weird creepy
what do you make of this cartoon the new
cartoon the most shocking here about
this story is that it's a reboot so I
didn't know you know who knew that there
was a show called The Proud Family
before this oh really yeah I didn't
reboot see you actually read the
information we gave you yeah you know I
do a little research yeah
they laid off 8 000 people
yeah that's great so for those 8 000
people you know I guess it's even a
smaller world after all
listen I just want to take the survey
and ask those 7 000 people if they still
think Disney is the happiest place on
Earth yes exactly but the reason why
they did that was because they weren't
paying them away so the way they could
take care of themselves it was the most
they get paid so unbelow poverty that
they can't afford to support themselves
working at Disney so instead of raising
to pay to where they could pay their
bills they got rid of them so they
actually did them a favor there you go
you know what's great on the
unemployment line people are going to
look behind them and see uh Buzz
Lightyear behind I'm like wow that's
weird what the hell is he doing here
Cat last word to you uh um
what did you think of this are we like
the problem is none of this stuff will
ever go away because no one's ever has
the guts to stop it okay well I was just
really confused because of my family
made all this money from slavery why did
my grandparents and their nine kids live
in a two bedroom one bathroom house in a
terrible neighborhood
I'd be like well my great-grandma came
here from Poland in like 1913. it's
obviously a more nuanced conversation
it's an important conversation to have
but when I am a mom someday I think what
I will be looking for in TV here's an
announcement yeah what I will be looking
for in TV will be something that stops
conversation right because you'll
probably get tired of talking to some
kid all day yeah that's true yeah you
don't want stuff that starts
conversation yeah like oh you're gonna
have questions for me that's not why I
put this on yeah
it's how I homeschooled my kids through
the entire pandemic to learn to read you
turn on the TV subtitles boom there you
go
and they said you can't be a drunk and a
good mom
not her hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else